[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors pour commencer cette rencontre
haïkus en fait je vais en ville à
commencer par un mot simple simple comme
bonjour
alors bonjour à tous bonjour à toutes et
je suis ravi ravi de vous rencontrer
c'est vrai qu'on ne se connaît pas du
moi je ne connais pas la majorité
d'entre vous mais sans que vous le
sachiez je sais une chose sur vous sur
vous tous sur chacun d'entre eux je sais
que nous avons un point commun
quelque chose qui nous lie et je vais
vous le démontrer en quelques secondes
quand je vous invite tous mais tous à
plonger la main dans votre sac ou
glisser une main dans votre poche et de
me sortir une clé une clé celle que vous
avez à lézinnes je vous lance cette
invitation
et de me l'a présenté eh bien non ah
vous avez tous des clés en fait super
une clé de clé trois clés quatre clips
c'est un classique les bons vous doutez
bien que je vais pas tout les
comptabiliser vous êtes beaucoup trop
nombreux mais en fait parmi toutes ses
clés de soissons je suis certaine de
trouver est une clé de voiture la clé
d'une maison ou d'un appartement d'une
boîte aux lettres peut-être même d'un
journal intime qui c'est une clé votre
clé mais mesurez-vous l'importance de
l'utilité première de cet objet son
utilité d'un objet tellement banal une
utilité qui se cantonne à deux mois
ferme et ouvrir est ce que vous imaginez
sans je ne pense pas alors moi aussi
j'ai une clé je vous la présenter sa
basse et la climat maison et nous avons
tous cette clé la clé d'une maison ou
d'un appartement qui nous permet de
fermer d'autres portes et de mettre en
sécurité ce qu'on a de plus précieux
d'important se soit pas personnellement
à ce sont ils photos de mes enfants de
ma famille quelques boucs à quelques bd
quelques objets quelques bien des choses
qui coûtent une clé mais en fait
aujourd'hui j'avais surtout envie de
vous parler de cette clé
cette clé qui à mes yeux est très chère
est importante en cette clé
c'est un peu elle peut aussi résumer un
peu toutes les valeurs que nous étions
défendre au sein de notre association en
cette clé je pourrais lui donner un nom
la clé de la liberté la clé de l'égalité
la clé de la fraternité
la clé de la solidarité se voyait sa
basse est la clé qui demain ouvrira et
fermera la bagagerie qui sera destiné
aux personnes sans domicile à rennes
[Applaudissements]
on savait ce projet il va naître grâce à
une campagne à une campagne que nous
avons menées grâce à une forte
mobilisation des rennais autour de ce
projet grâce au budget participatif de
la ville des gens des personnes qui nous
ont offert leurs voix pour que ce projet
devienne l'horaire alors la bagagerie
effectivement elle sera destinée à des
personnes dans le besoin
les plus démunis alors des personnes que
vous croisez comme moi dans les rues de
rennes des personnes que je connais des
personnes qui habitent pour certains
d'entre vous même à la même adresse que
vous en bas de chez vous alors c'est
vrai ils n'ont pas de toit est-ce que
vous doutez bien que leur priorité est
de trouver un logement
ils n'ont pas de toit mais ils ont tous
une maison comme ils le disent si
justement leur maison
les sacs à dos pour certains des caddies
des cabas des sacs plastiques pour
certains une voiture et dans leur maison
va aussi sont des choses précieuses et
chose importante des choses qu'ils
comptaient même vital leur nourriture
leur duvet leurs produits d'hygiène
leurs papiers quand ils sont pas
retrouvés humides des croquettes pour
leur chien des choses qui comptent mais
ils n'ont pas de sou les sourds la
bagagerie elle s'avéra ça en fait alors
offrir ce service pour enfin qu'ils
puissent mettre en toute sécurité leurs
affaires mais en fait ce que j'avais
envie que vous compreniez aujourd'hui
c'est que balla bagagi ne sera pas que
ça en fait parce que ce sera aussi une
passerelle à une passerelle pour aller
vers le mieux un véritable tremplin vers
la réinsertion
voyez ces gagnants mobilité et être plus
léger gagne en mobilité pour se rendre à
un rendez-vous administratif un
rendez-vous de soins sans sac à dos la
plupart font toutes ces démarches à pied
c'est pouvoir se rendre en entretien
d'embauché
sans que l'employeur devine une partie
de leur vie égalité
ils n'ont pas forcément envie que ça va
c'est aussi ce bonheur tout simple que
nous avons tous de s'installer en
terrasse de café tranquillement sans
attirer les gars sans être stigmatisés
être invisible se bouge le trouve très
fort je l' ai beaucoup trop entendu et
en fait ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est
qu'effectivement ce projet je les fais
pour eux mais aussi avec eux parce
qu'ils ont envie de s'investir
s'investir dans l'organisation
nous ferons tous demain pour que les
bénéficiaires de vielles geste ô terre
parce qu'ils ont envie de porter ils ont
envie de porter des actions ils ont ils
ont envie de créer des services nouveaux
os à cette bagagerie mais ont réellement
envie de les partager avec vous être
acteur ne put être dans l'exclusion est
réellement être dans l'inclusion faire
leur part alors je me dis toujours
qu'effectivement bas très sincèrement on
est tous capables tous capables de faire
de faire sa part tous capables d'agir
il n'y a pas de grosses parts ou de
petite part loin de là mais ça on peut
simplement se cantonner à des réflexions
à du bénévolat dans des associations
tendre une main me dis toujours qu'il
faut oser oser faire on peut être par
exemple tous foot solidarité la
solidarité c'est un bouquet unis si
demain par exemple si aujourd'hui vous
êtes séduit par ce projet portait le nom
de ville
je rêverais que d'autres villes soient
contaminés qui l'épidémie joyeuse autour
de ce projet faites-le osé mais
vous inquiétez pas demain nous voulons
ce round invitation parce que demain ils
ont plus que jamais besoin de vous nous
aurons besoin de fonds pour assurer son
fonctionnement
nous aurons besoin de bénévoles nous
aurons besoin d'énergie nous vous
tendrons la main
on sait tous à la bagagerie
mais voyons aujourd'hui je suis seul
sous les projecteurs mais en fait ce
projet je le porte avec une personne une
personne qui m'est cher aujourd'hui une
personne que j'ai rencontrée il ya
simplement trois mois une rencontre de
rue comme haïti une rencontre qui a
commencé par un simple bonjour
cette personne c'est gwen gwendoline
cherel alors elle aurait pu vous parler
de plein de choses en fait elle aurait
pu vous dire plein de choses mais madame
à la préférée reste en loge à continue à
se faire bichonner en fait voilà elle
aurait pu vous parler de cette rupture
sentimentale en fait qui l'a amené à la
rue parce qu'on ne naît pas sdf on le
devient
face à des obstacles souvent on n'arrive
pas à surmonter elle aurait pu vous
parler aussi de toute cette période où
elle devait trouver un lieu pour dormir
en sécurité et se réveiller le lendemain
pour aller travailler
secundo ni les paysagistes prophète
malheureusement la fatigue le stress l'a
emporté perte de son emploi
et puis on a appris à se connaître en
fait à se dévoiler l'une à l'autre et
puis on a appris à s'aimer en fait
puis c'est vrai que j'apprends que ça
fait six ans six ans que ces sacs à dos
sont devenus sa maison et à chaque
rencontre en fait moi j'étais chamboulé
ces mots étaient tellement profond et
d'une vérité tellement profonde que
l'agent on était perturbé et puis je
savais que en fait c'était l'amour qu'il
avait des trucs quelque part
mais je serais vous et que c'était
l'amour qu'il avait qui lui donnait
envie de pouvoir s'en sortir
en fait elle a envie de récupérer la
femme qu'elle aime aujourd'hui en fait
et je trouve ça tellement bourg j'ai
voulu embarquer voilà lui tente juste
sept mois alors wendo mis à la porte et
grosse partie de ce projet l appart
apporter une grosse partie de ce projet
pendant toute cette campagne
elle servait tous les matins pour aller
faire campagne à la rue pourrait essayer
de collecter de voix pour que ce projet
laisse et sage le mesure j'en suis même
reconnaissante et très admirative alors
aujourd'hui avant de vous quitter
j'avais envie de moi de vous offrir une
clé celle de la reconnaissance celle
qu'on a tous entre nos mains en fait et
cette clé j'avais envie que joe frier
que vous le vrillé à gwen mais c'est
pour ça que je mente tous de vous lever
et applaudir bois d'olives
[Applaudissements]
c'est ce truc
la regarde
[Applaudissements]
où aller
à la pointe de l'île
[Applaudissements]
nokia
[Musique]
m